lancer 2D attribution d'une boîte
sélection de matériaux et place à la
création ce sont les règles que c'était
fixées agadezo pour réaliser
l'exposition
ludique le processus de création se
faisait autour du jeu et tous les
Yvelines étaient invités à participer
[Musique]
en fait quand les médiathèques mon
sollicité sur ce projet donc dont la
donc le brief c'était de faire une
action collective qui relie les publics
j'ai proposé cette notion de totem parce
que ça m'intéressait d'être dans la
construction de l'amitié il n'y a pas
besoin entre guillemets d'être habité
ici ou ailleurs on a on est relié par
un lien un peu indéfectible qui est
invisible mais qui est là entre humains
en fait et je trouve que c'est ce
qu'elle les met en valeur et en lumière
c'est en juillet dernier kayad bezot a
démarré son processus de création à
partir d'ateliers de rue l'exposition a
pris forme dans plusieurs villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines notre action
culturelle au sein de l'agglomération
c'est entre autres de créer du lien
entre les habitants de créer du lien
entre les villes et de faire corps pour
créer cette identité de territoire à
laquelle nous sommes attachés des copies
de l'oeuvre finale seront exposées dans
chaque médiathèque de l'agglomération et
ce de manière définitive
[Musique]